as expected vladimir putin has launched
a full-scale russian invasion of ukraine
the invasion extended far beyond the
contested breakaway regions in the east
of the country going all the way to the
nation's capital of kiev where
explosions could be heard on television
in the middle of the night
ukrainians who who resist oh
i tell you what i just heard a big bang
right here behind me i thought we
shouldn't have done a live shot here
there are big explosions taking place
in kiev right now
um i can't see where they're taking
place from this vantage point here on
top of the roof of the hotel in central
kiev and
i can't explain what they are but i
heard four or five explosions a few
moments ago i don't know whether our
viewers or whether you in the studio
there could hear uh
what i just heard
there is going to be lots of finger
pointing over the next few days there's
going to be a lot of damage control from
our own country's ruling elite
but you should make no mistake
this is joe biden's fault
everybody knew that putin wanted to
conquer ukraine along with many other
neighboring countries putin invaded
georgia under george w bush he invaded
crimea under obama he paused the
invasions under donald trump now he has
invaded ukraine under biden it is not
just biden's bad luck that putin chose
this moment to invade he is invading
ukraine right now because joe biden made
specific decisions that encouraged him
to do it
donald trump instituted sanctions on
russia
biden lifted those sanctions
trump shut down putin's nordstrom 2
pipeline which would give russia direct
access to the european oil market joe
biden gave the green light to the
pipeline removing all the leverage that
ukraine ever had
trump kept putin on his toes and in line
biden literally invited him to invade
ukraine just so long as the invasion
were only a minor incursion
i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc wow really
tough talk there's the leader of the
free world all right mr alligator you
can have my pinky but you'd better not
take the whole hand there it is don't
don't you better you can have okay you
can have two fingers but don't okay well
that's american leadership no wonder we
see what's happening now in ukraine it
is impossible to prove a counterfactual
but it seems safe to say that this would
not be happening right now if donald
trump were still president but elections
even dubious elections have consequences
the jello-headed cadaver currently
occupying the oval office has been in
power for just one year and already the
post-cold war world order is crumbling a
high price to pay but hey
at least no more mean tweets i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday from cool
papa j magic i think he's been my
favorite commenter before he said
for all the people who say legalizing
weed is not a slippery slope into
legalizing harder drugs think again a
few states legalize weed and just a
couple short years later we have
government issued crack pipes that's
true and and president crack pipe
it doesn't just seem to be messing up
domestic policy he seems to be
disturbing the entire world order
i don't know about you but with this guy
in charge i do not feel particularly
safe now when you want your home to be
safe your family to be safe your stuff
to be safe i recommend you check out
ring you know about the ring video
doorbell i know you know because i've
been telling you about it for years how
great it is you can see who's at your
doorstep whether you're in the house at
the office on a beach on the other side
of the world well did you know that ring
makes an alarm ring makes an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring best
of all you can easily install it
yourself
even i can install it i'm not the
handiest guy in the world i need to call
contractors to put a light bulb in but
ring it's so easy you can install it
10-15 minutes you can get all the
sensors for motion doors and windows
that will work on any house and
apartment just like yours
you get notified right on your phone
whenever anything is detected and it's
more than just security you can add
sensors that will help to protect your
home from flood freeze and fire too i
love ring i absolutely love it i really
appreciate ring in particular because
they have been with this show from day
one so if you want to support the show
if you want to protect your home your
family your stuff go get rings award
winning alarm go to ring.com knowles
know wlas to get a great deal on a ring
alarm home security kit today ring.com
stephen king
the vehemently anti-trump
anti-republican anti-conservative
horror novelist stephen king
tweeted out two days ago
mr putin has made a serious
miscalculation
he forgot he's no longer dealing with
trump
that tweet
didn't even make it 24 hours
one day let's be generous that tweet
made it one day and that tweet aged like
milk
and we all knew it would when i read it
the first time i thought the debate
right now is not over whether putin is
going to invade ukraine or not that that
is guaranteed to happen you would have
to be
living on another planet or so deeply
profoundly ignorant of world affairs and
politics to believe that some some sort
of invasion is not going to happen now
there was a real debate over is putin
just going to go in to the eastern part
of the country or is he going to go all
the way to kiev and conquer the whole
country
but
it turns out that a whole lot of
ideologues
radical leftists who are these are not
fringe people stephen king is a very
prominent figure in america he's a
cultural elite he's been one for a
decade upon decade he really seemed to
believe that vladimir putin was going to
be afraid of mr come on man
well did you hear what biden did to corn
pop back at the pool in delaware did you
that you know that thing that also never
happened
this guy joe biden one of the most
incompetent politicians we've ever had
in our country he's competent at getting
and staying elected i don't want to take
that away from him he's very good at
that but he hasn't accomplished
anything in his whole career not one
single thing the closest thing to an
accomplishment in joe biden's career was
passing that crime bill in 1994 with the
help of a lot of other people that was
the best thing he ever did and then he
ran away from it in the 2020 campaign so
you knew the minute this guy found his
way into the oval office you knew things
are not going to get better
but you would have to be just mainlining
cnn you would have to be in such an echo
chamber of the establishment propaganda
to really believe that putin walked all
over trump and was was petrified of joe
biden it's insane it's completely the
opposite the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting
putin didn't aggress under trump and
then biden's in office for one year and
already he's conquering an entire
country upsetting the world order that
we have had for over 30 years now
didn't make it one day you know we talk
about
russian propaganda the russians are
known for their propaganda particularly
the russian communists and don't forget
vladimir putin was a kgb spy and he was
a really good kgb spy
he was not good in the moral sense good
in the tactical sense
this guy
is a killer
this guy
was a very serious player during the
soviet union and so we focus on how
silly the russian propaganda is what
about our own propaganda what about cnn
cnn now is doing some actual reporting
for the first time in probably a decade
they've got a reporter on the ground
it's inspiring to see
i'm glad i hope cnn does more of that
you know journalism reporting but
beyond that one guy you've got cnn nbc
the washington post the new york times
they're they're just pravda they're ju
they're just the american regime's
equivalent of russian propaganda
and if you really believed all that
stuff if you weren't tuning into this
show if you weren't reading the daily
wire if you weren't talking to other
people when you can on social media
you would really believe there's no way
putin's gonna you would be shocked when
you heard those bombs go off in kiev
and now
maybe the most insulting aspect of this
of this complete
botched mayhem that that biden is
presiding over
is that the ruling establishment in the
united states is now exploiting the war
in ukraine to justify their own failures
on every other front i couldn't believe
this one i should believe it at this
point but i but i couldn't this was in
one of one of the news network cbs or
nbc
yes with cbs news how the ukraine crisis
is already hitting americans wallets
oh well that's where the ukraine crisis
has been going on for 12 hours now so
please tell me cbs how is it already
hitting our wallets well they tweet the
us economy has been hit with increased
gas prices inflation and supply chain
issues due to the ukraine crisis
you know that thing that just happened
like five minutes ago that's that's the
reason for all of the problems that
you've been experiencing for months and
even years now yeah it's ukraine it's
not biden's fault
it's not dr fauci's fault
it's not the chinese communists fault
even it's not because of the covid
lockdowns that all the democrats were
pushing
it's not because the democrats are
shutting down american energy production
and relying more on hostile foreign
powers so now you're going to see your
gas prices go up a lot more in the next
few weeks no no no it's not it's yeah
inflation it's not because we're just
printing money willy-nilly and giving it
away to everybody and just trying to
spend our way out of temporary political
crises no no no
it's uh
putin yeah that's it that's why it's not
putin it's biden it's biden
frankly even on the invasion of ukraine
whose fault is it at the at the
particular judgment when all of us are
standing before our maker putin is going
to have to answer for his actions right
he's the one
leading this war into ukraine
but we all knew putin wanted to do it
everyone with two brain cells together
to rub together knew that putin wanted
to do it
joe biden let it happen joe biden
incentivized it to happen joe biden made
stupid error after stupid error after
mind-numbingly
incomprehensibly stupid error
and
putin took advantage
up to and including well if it's just a
minor incursion
okay why don't you roll out the red
carpet for him
what a freaking putts i'm sorry
ah it's it's so dishonest
this is what really struck me about this
article in cbs it's so dishonest you'll
you'll see this a lot i'll give you
another example of it they'll say here's
job creation under different presidents
and you'll see you know biden job
creation he's created a gazillion jobs
trump he lost a lot of jobs he created
like no jobs and you think well i don't
remember i don't think that's what
happened i remember the trump
administration and he made a lot of jobs
well what what happened well it's
because
the when the libs and the statisticians
are coming up with these numbers they
count the covet lockdowns which was a
voluntary giving up of jobs because the
government said you can't go to work
you've all got to lock down and then
when joe biden under joe biden
establishment said okay you can go back
to work so then the jobs go back up
again it's so dishonest it's pure
propaganda pravda couldn't have done any
better
it's kind of hard to sleep well at night
with all this craziness in the world but
if you want to sleep well at night you
should check out bowlin branch right now
go to bolinbranch.com use promo code
michael you will get the softest organic
sheets on the market they get better
with every wash i have i really love
bowling branch they've supported this
show since its very earliest days
and i remember the first time they sent
me some sheets was before i got married
and i tried out the sheets and i thought
oh my gosh these sheets they actually
are as good as they say they are there's
a reason multiple u.s presidents have
slept on these sheets it feels like the
fanciest hotel you've ever slept on and
then what happens i get married i need
to get a bigger bed so we get the big
bad i go i'll tell you what i go i buy
the sheets i say they're worth every
single penny i use promo code michael so
that i get to save a lot of money on it
they're really good the highest quality
organic cotton and not too hot not too
cool you're going to feel like royalty
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code michael at checkout that's
bowlin branch b-o-l-l and branch dot com
promo code michael the dishonesty of our
ruling class is enough to make you
laugh hysterically or scream
or cry those are those are your options
so pick one i guess i generally choose
to laugh at it but it's getting harder
and harder because it's so clear that
our rulers hold us in absolute disdain
they have nothing but contempt for us
and they mock us constantly bill gates
bill gates who
he doesn't hold any position in the
government
and yet he's everywhere he's always on
tv telling us what vaccines to take he's
always meeting with world leaders i
guess because he's a very rich guy he
seems to be dictating a whole lot of not
just american public policy but public
policy around the world then he's in
africa pushing his public public policy
agenda he's got
a ton of power and he has been rabid
about kovid
not only on getting us all to take the
extremely effective 100 safe and
effective vaccines that are totally
going to stop transmission and infection
and whoopsie daisy i guess they're not
totally doing that but anyway you've got
to take the second shot or the third or
the fourth maybe the fifth shot but
those of you who haven't taken the first
shot yet you have to take it because
it's so effective but it's not going to
be effective enough to stop you from
taking the fifth okay bill gates has
been doing that now he's making fun of
people who won't wear the mask so you
you don't want to wear the mask he says
well
well you might as well take off your
pants
i think there are a lot of people in
america who are confused about whether
they should be wearing a mask and in the
united kingdom for example they've
scrapped that all together well that's
interesting you know what is the
downside of wearing a mask i mean it's
got to be tough you know you have to
wear pants uh i mean this is tough stuff
these societies are so cruel why did
they make you wear pants i'm trying to
figure it out
we're very glad you have yours on um
that will be on the web
will be on the web
boy we got a regular don rickles here
don't we oh there's old rodney
dangerfield that bill that cut up bill
gates
well i know my soul was so awful it's so
terrible what a cruel society would you
come on just wear your masks guys
says the man
not wearing a mask on a panel with four
other people none of whom are wearing
masks speaking to an audience which may
or may not be wearing masks but i highly
doubt it
i don't know maybe they are maybe
they're not but i doubt it and i doubt
that
any of those people
in that room including the audience in
their regular personal lives ever wear
the masks because it's not for them
because bill gates is clean he's clean
he's an elite he can do what he wants
he's not a filthy dirty peasant like you
are
you need to wear it to protect him from
your filth that's why that's why you've
got to wear it
come on what's the big deal about
wearing a mask i don't know why aren't
you wearing one then
if it's not a big deal if it's totally
normal if it's just like putting pants
on in the morning why are you bill gates
wearing pants but not wearing a mask
because wearing the mask is degrading
it's inhuman we are social creatures as
aristotle says we are the political
animal we like to see one another we
like to speak to one another that's a
distinguishing feature of being a human
we like to see each other's smiles we
like to see each other's faces it
conveys a lot of information a lot of
emotion it helps us get along together
in society that's that's oh and also by
the way
to quote lyanna wen the chief medical
analyst at cnn
the face masks the cloth face masks are
nothing more than facial decoration
that's the other reason i guess so
what's the big deal
it's just like wearing pants guys come
on
what a terrible society
they're they're different pants and
masks are different bill gates and you
know it because you don't wear it but it
doesn't matter because there's one set
of rules for him and one set of rules
for everybody else
you're seeing this in action in canada
right now
uh
prime minister uh justin castro
just justine justin fidel castro up in
canada
uh he has now put down the truckers yeah
the trucker convoy pushing against his
draconian fouchy ouchy mandate uh they
held him off for several weeks they got
some concessions at least out of the
local governments and then trudeau
suspended the rule of law invoked the
emergencies act
went after the truckers beat them up in
the streets arrested them stole their
property and now now
justin trudeau that great defender of
liberal democracy
he's putting away the emergencies act
and restoring the rule of law
we were very clear that the use of the
emergencies act would be limited
in time
when we invoked it it would be in place
for up to 30 days but we said that we
would lift it as soon as possible
we've held updates and briefs with
ministers and officials every day often
multiple times a day
and today
after careful consideration we're ready
to confirm that the situation is no
longer an emergency
therefore the federal government will be
ending the use of the emergencies act
we are confident
that existing laws and bylaws are now
sufficient to keep people safe
of course we'll continue to be there to
support provincial and local authorities
if and when needed
there he is cincinnatus justin trudeau
regular old washington trudeau
putting away his emergency powers and
restoring the rule of law
after he totally won
after he through sheer brute force and
tyranny of will completely put down the
truckers
and then not only did he put down the
truckers
but
threw in in jail confiscated their
property threatened to kill their dogs
remember that they actually the ottawa
bylaw services
threatened to
take and kill the puppies of the
trucking protesters
after that he says okay i've completely
quashed this uprising here this popular
protest
now i'm going to restore the rule of law
very easy for him to do he won
he won and had he not won he'd still
have the emergency powers and he'd still
be fighting down there is there is
nothing orderly or principled about
what we're seeing in canada certainly
not what we're seeing in ukraine what we
are seeing is sheer
tyranny of will power politics i'm going
to cudgel you over the head and the way
they do it in eastern europe is is
pretty violent and an actual historic
event right now and what they're doing
in canada
is being done with a smile but make no
mistake there is no order here there is
not a whole lot of logic here this is a
political reordering of our society
in some cases being done with a grimace
in some cases being done with a smile
the opinion of a great many people
forget canada for a second forget
america's hat come back down to america
the the opinion of a great many people
is that
conservative
traditional
christian overwhelmingly americans who
don't want their way of life completely
upended who don't want their rights
suspended who don't want their
traditional liberties taken away
they can't be reasoned with
we can't be reasoned with we can't be
allowed to express our voice this is why
when we vote and we elect someone like
donald trump that's a threat to
democracy how the hell is it a threat to
democracy just because the people voted
for a guy
well no but they didn't vote for the
right guy they really shouldn't have
been allowed to vote in the first place
according to one texas middle middle
school teacher was just caught on camera
conservative christians
they just they just need to get coveted
and die
that's what's frustrating
because of
politics
because of concerns
little hard to hear what these cackling
hens are saying which says if if they
had just all given up their rights and
all taken the fouchyache right away then
it would be over there would be no covet
but they haven't done they just need to
die these conservative christians so
sure this middle school teacher
i guess she didn't say it in the front
of a classroom
she just said it to other teachers and
administrators
but what do you think she's teaching
what do you think the kids are being
taught
they're being taught that if you
descend from this
regime
you deserve death you just need to go
away not there she's not even saying you
need to go to the gulag
man
stalin seems like a squish compared to
these ladies
these ladies are a lot tougher these
these radicals in middle schools and
high schools and colleges
they would make stalin blush
not no they shouldn't even go to a
forced labor camp they should just die
that's what's got to happen
speaking of death
there is
a fascinating story that has just come
out of the world of science that has
everybody shocked wondering in awe
scratching their head everybody except
for
regular old christians regular regular
old traditional religious people
who
have long known what this new scientific
discovery this kind of fluke of a
scientific discovery has found namely
that when people die
their lives really do flash before
their eyes you hear about it and sort of
anecdotes here and there you hear about
it certainly in religion
as you know you're accountable for your
whole life but now finally the
scientists have caught up to what
ordinary people have known for thousands
of years
that's very important by the way
that right now
you go check out podium go to podium.com
knowles podium
is just an
all-encompassing business solution i
don't know how else to put it it makes
running your business as easy as sending
a text if you own a business you know
there are not enough hours in a day to
waste playing phone tag the list of
customers you need to reach does not get
any shorter especially when business is
good that's why local businesses
everywhere turn to podium podium makes
every interaction as easy as sending a
text so everything that makes your
business great can get done faster
podium is not just a better way to
communicate
better way to do everything gather
reviews collect payments even market to
your customers podium makes it all as
easy as pressing send you won't just
free up more time you'll grow your
business and get more done with podium
you'll close deals with customers before
the competition even has a chance to
call them back join more than 100 000
businesses that already use podium to
streamline their customer interactions
get started for free at podium.com slash
knowles or sign up for a podium account
get a free credit card reader
restriction supply that's podium.com
knowles one of daily wire's newest
projects incredibly exciting the enemy
within a new docu-series featuring
acclaimed journalist and expert in
national threats lee smith smith
uncovers a political coup orchestrated
by america's ruling class
to generate their own wealth and power
at the expense of the american people's
safety and freedom in the third episode
lee uncovers the infiltration of
america's universities by chinese spies
students and the ccp along with american
professors who've sold their allegiance
to the chinese communist party for
bribes check out the trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
[Music]
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
all episodes of the enemy within are
streaming now exclusively at the daily
wire so if you are not a member now is
the time to change that head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to join us today
also
in ben shapiro's new show the search you
will join him and his closest friends as
they head to ben's favorite local spots
to dive into deep conversations that you
do not get to hear when the camera is
not rolling first he had jordan peterson
and the second episode of the search
will feature his other very good friend
the highly lauded historian neil
ferguson this is an excellent
conversation i highly recommend you
check it out the episode releases
tonight thursday the 24th and will be
exclusive to daily wire members so if
you're not currently a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
we'll be right back with a lot more
a first of its kind study has captured a
man's brain activity
seconds before and after his death
and what it found is shocking to
everyone who
doesn't go to church on sunday i guess
which these days is probably the great
majority of people
so it just it just so happened that the
guy was getting a brain scan and he died
as he was getting his brain scan so
they've got the brain scan data of
what's going on in his head as he dies
this has not been done before as far as
any any one knows
and the research
which was published
in frontiers in aging neuroscience
describes a man
who was connected to this brain scan he
suffered a heart attack he died and they
showed the different types of brain
waves that were going through his his
head before during and even 15 seconds
after his heart stopped beating
what
some of the researchers found is
surprisingly after the heart starts
pumping blood into the brain these
oscillations keep going so that that was
extremely surprising for us to see
the
you get an a flash
of
everything you've ever done
you just get a flash of all of your
memories just come flooding back to you
in this instant
and the person who called my attention
to this news story
is my wife
you know sweet little alisa
she has got a really good gut on
political matters on cultural matters
and on religious matters too she's just
got this this way of seeing things that
cuts through all of the kind of
pretentious jargon and all the clinical
newfangled wording and so she sends me
this article and she said hey are they
just talking about the particular
judgment
i said oh my gosh
that's
we're all scratching our heads trying to
make sense of this scientific discovery
of a phenomenon that we'd heard
anecdotally for many many years
christians have talked about this
forever they say at the moment of your
death at the exact moment of your death
there is a particular judgment
you're before your maker right you know
all the imagery you go up you're at the
gate of saint peter you you meet your
maker and you're answerable for the
things that you've done
now christians believe that christ's
death on the cross
he redeems man from his sins and you
receive that immense grace
and yet still and you read this
throughout the gospels you are
accountable for the things that you have
done
in that in that very instant of death
and what we are seeing here i don't want
to sound too much like a hippy dippy new
age guy but we what we are seeing here
is a physical representation of a
spiritual truth
that people frankly not even just
christians but people of many
even even certain pagan religious
intuitions have been aware of for a long
time though most precisely it's the
christians who have been aware of this
the the longer i live
the the more i realize
that
peasant
farmers and shepherds in the middle east
2000 and 3000 years ago
pretty much figured out everything and
they figured it out because god told
them and they figured it out in part
because they had use of their reason and
that the the further we get from that
ancient world
the the more technology we get the more
i ipads and ipods and fancy computers
and genius scientists in their lab cuts
with their stethoscopes the dumber we
get because we're rediscovering things
that we already knew were true
that i actually think a lot of this just
comes back to yeah good
we should do good not do bad we should
follow god not the devil
we should there is there is virtue there
is a moral order in in the western
civilization
we are just starting to come out of 150
200 maybe even 300 years
of
fashionable
atheism materialism all these kooky
random theories that tried to get away
from the basic truths of religion
and we're realizing
that it just doesn't hold up
the idea that there's no such thing as
good or bad there's no moral order it's
just whatever well that doesn't seem to
be true no one really
people who try to live their lives this
way go crazy
that actually our bodies don't matter at
all we're just spirits well no i don't
think so you look at a drag queen you
think this is not someone who's totally
stable who totally is the right idea
people who live their lives like total
hedonists just like meat puppets trying
to consume pleasure all the time
actually they live bad lives it just
doesn't just doesn't work
just doesn't hold up people who try to
upend natural
the the natural longings of man's soul
who try to recreate man the communist
project of the 20th 19th and 20th
centuries the nazi the project the
fascist project the things that try to
reorder the soul just doesn't work just
doesn't work
and i don't whether the brain scan is
showing this or not it seems to be
pretty clear to me
that
that the the basic facts of life life
are actually pretty simple they might
not be easy they're not always easy to
follow but they are pretty simple
we need to educate people this way we've
got a whole generation that is so
extremely miseducated they can't tell
good from bad true from false boys from
girls they can't tell anything and this
is by design this is not not just
because people's iqs are diminishing
they're not diminishing it's because
they're not being taught things in
school because they've got kooky
teachers who are filling their heads
with lies and this is being encouraged
by our political order there is today
the single dumbest article on the
internet
that that great distinction goes to
sarah jones
writing in new york magazine
she writes about household tyrants
household tyrants and she's referring to
parents
sarah jones
hates the parents movement you know the
parents showing up to school boards
parents mostly moms but some dads too of
all races shapes sizes geography showing
up and saying hey stop filling my kids
heads with crazy racial theories crazy
sexual theories stop trying to turn
little johnny into little jane you
psychos just teach him his reading
writing and arithmetic
well this this woman sarah jones says
this is really bad
this is really bad
she says parents don't lack rights in
the united states
they already enjoy the wide freedom to
educate their children as they wish
including at home or in private schools
they can raise their children to be
christians or witches or both the state
does not interfere
maybe the state should interfere if
you're raising your kid to be a witch
but another battle for another time
liberals are generally satisfied with
the state of affairs there's no appetite
to prohibit parents from raising their
children and even the most hate-filled
churches oh there's not darling you
don't think so there's no there's no
effort underway to diminish school
choice by the democratic party fighting
tooth and nail to stop school choice
fighting to curb the rights of parents
in homeschooling and then of course
fighting to control the curricula of the
public schools to take away the rights
of local community there's none of that
you sure that seems a little dishonest
to me
he says yet the right believes as if it
behaves as if parental rights were under
sustained and serious attack as if the
parent has been dislodged from a high
place and as texas governor greg abbott
said should be restored the gop's
position on parental rights is not
entirely coherent any attempt to ban
gender confirming therapy for
transgender children so hold on i just
want to define that term for a second
gender confirming therapy
is the opposite of gender confirming
therapy
what the what the libs refer to as
gender confirming therapy is when you
tell a confused boy that he's a girl
which would be the opposite that would
be gender confusing therapy
but she says any attempt to ban sick
perverts from trying to trans your kid
theoretically infringes on the rights of
the parent but this hasn't dissuaded the
party from its attacks on trans rights
in texas attorney general ken paxton had
previously issued an opinion defining
gender affirming care as child abuse
which it is trans children and their
families must now fear the long arm of
the state which will reach into their
most private and personal fears so i
want to be fair to this woman sarah
jones what she's saying is look you got
all these parents showing up and saying
stop transiting my kids you perverts and
you know fair enough that's where most
parents are but but then in response to
this some people like in texas have come
in and passed laws saying that that
transiting the kids and chopping up
their their genitals and mutilating
their bodies and trying to pretend that
they're a different sex that that is
child abuse which it obviously is and
therefore that infringes on the rights
of the handful of confused pervert
parents who are trying to trans their
own kids
so see
you hypocrite republicans you're not
really standing for parental rights
okay
fair enough you're right
republicans right now in trying to give
parents
the ability to at least see what's going
on in the curricula
curriculum transparency
the right to decide that teachers should
not teach kooky sexual theories and to
first graders
that pro that stands up for the rights
of the vast majority of parents who
don't want that sort of thing but yes it
does infringe on the rights of a handful
of extremely confused or extremely
ignorant or extremely perverted people
who are trying to trans six-year-olds
that's that's good we like that
we stand up for parental rights as a
procedure generally speaking
but there is more than that it's more
than just the procedure
we stand up for what is right
for what is good for what is just
i know we should not we do not defend
the rights of parents
to do anything we
for instance we don't defend the right
of parents to abuse their children
whether that means
punching them in the face repeatedly
whether that means depriving them of
food or whether that means cutting off
their genitals we don't defend that we
do defend the rights of parents
generally
and in this particular case by the way
where you've got kooky
educational establishment trying to
trans your kids and ordinary normal
parents saying don't trans my kids we
are defending the rights of parents
there because they're right
and the educational ambition is wrong
what sarah jones points out she says the
right's real ambition is not restoration
but expansion they want to create new
rights on top of the privileges parents
already enjoy
in the party's view parental rights both
supersede and exist in conflict with the
rights of the child the right insists
that what's good for parents is good for
kids this is not necessarily the truth
as any queer person can say in return
what the idea that children are already
people with thoughts and needs
independent of their parents never
factors into the party's position at all
the parental rights movement is not new
the concept is associated with some
christian homeschool activists who
lobbied for a constitutional amendment
that would enshrine the right of a
parent to teach their kid at home
the language might sound familiar
uh the liberty appearance to direct the
upbringing education and care of their
children's fundamental right okay so
what what they're saying is look the
kids have rights
if they this is such a creepy idea
to say that the kids have the right to
make
life-changing permanent sexual decisions
because
the
necessary logical conclusion of that
idea the the inevitable logical
conclusion of a five-year-old has the
right to mutilate his body or a
ten-year-old has the right to take
puberty blockers to try to look more
like a girl when he's a boy or vice
versa the inevitable conclusion
is that children can consent to have sex
with adults that's the inevitable
conclusion
it seems far-fetched does it i don't
think it really does
surely if a child can make a if the
child has the reason and the judgment
and the maturity to make a permanent
sexual decision
surely that child can make a temporary
sexual decision
now i for one i guess i'm a little
old-fashioned i'm a little old school i
think that little kids do not have the
judgment and the reason and the maturity
to make these kind of profound
significant decisions
certainly on sexual matters
the left doesn't believe that and the
left has been pushing this creepy stuff
for 100 years almost this goes back all
the way to the early 20th century to a
creepy
writer named wilhelm reich who i write
about him in my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is the number one bestseller
thanks to you thank you very much for
that
wilhelm reich
was this weirdo who said that the cause
of all the problems in the world war
discord disease even cancer the the
problem is that people don't have enough
orgasms seriously this is what he
believed he said therefore he had a box
he called it the orgone accumulator he
thought there was this sort of life
vital force floating in the ether called
orgones you need to get those and and
you would go into this box the oregon
accumulator and i don't know what you
did in the box but that would help you
to solve all the problems of the world
woody allen made fun of this idea as the
the
uh orgasmatron
right this is the uh was it woody allen
or mel brooks i forget easy to confuse
the guys
the the orgasmatron right and there were
a lot of people who who bought into this
jd salinger norm and male are very
serious people
when bernie sanders in the 1960s and 70s
wrote all these creepy essays in vermont
about how kids should should be able to
molest one another and that's fine and
and you can also you can read them in my
book speechless because i quote those
essays there
he was not unique he was he was speaking
to a prominent strain on the
intellectual left which was saying that
kids ought to have a ton of sexual
rights rights to have sex rights to
change their sex now
little tiny kids
and when parents say that's a bad idea
you've got creeps like sarah jones in
the new york magazine saying how dare
you you're infringing on the right of
little kids to do weird sex stuff these
are the people
who are
running the most powerful institutions
in our country
and there are more people who are
running on this
on this platform
you thought he was gone you thought he
had been vanquished
you thought he was just
circling around a whataburger parking
lot on his skateboard
he lost his race for texas senator to
ted cruz
he lost his race for president
pretty early on despite a lot of
establishment support in 2020 you know
who i'm talking about
america's favorite fake mexican
beto o'rourke who is now running for
governor of texas if at first and second
you don't succeed try and try and try
and try and try again
beto o'rourke is running for texas
governor on a platform
of transing
the kids
beto o'rourke just just released a new
ad about how gung-ho he is
to finally fulfill the will of texas
voters by transiting the kids
in the education system with texas i was
wondering what you were going to do to
protect my rights and my parents rights
to be able to put me on testosterone the
trans suicide rate has been the highest
it's ever been in texas since those
bills have been placed i mean we're
seeing people trying to take their lives
right now and it's a tough thing for us
to talk about but you're right we should
say it out loud so we speak about
everyone in this state with pride we
talk about a texas that is big enough
for all of us we target no one based on
any difference between us whether it is
the color of your skin your country of
national origin or the fact that you are
non-binary i think you're amazing i'm
proud of you i want you to do great
things in this state
and i'm going to support you in doing
that and i'm going to say that publicly
as the governor of this state that's
going to be a big change for texas it
just feels like he would be defending me
and caring about my rights as a trans
non-binary person it feels like he'd
care and he'd actually listen to our
voices and our thoughts about everything
beto o'rourke ran in 2020 on a platform
of hell yes we are going to take your
ar-15s
and now in 2022 he's running for
governor on a platform of hell yes
we are going to take your gonads
yes
hell yes we're going to trans your kids
this is very important you're amazing
you're amazing you're amazing wait hold
on hold on
the the confused people that beta or
work was talking to there and the
radical sexual activists that beta
o'rourke was talking to there
they might be perfectly nice people i
don't know i don't know them
they might be productive members of
society if they're showing up to beto
o'rourke rallies i highly doubt it but
maybe they are
maybe they volunteer and do good stuff
maybe i don't know maybe they you know
helped little old ladies across the
street
why are they amazing they're amazing
because they don't know what sex they
are or they're pretending to be a
different sex or they're insisting that
we get rid of bathrooms for women or
they're insisting we get rid of women's
and that's amazing
why is that amazing
am i amazing because i have swarthy's
skin
am i amazing because i have uh
what two or three inches of hair or a
little coiff is that
am i amazing because of some
way that i present myself to the world
no what it's not
it's not really amazing beto or work is
pandering here i guess the only the
thing that is amazing really
it this goes deeper than anything beta
or work has ever been able to think in
his entire life but there is something
amazing about the transgender issue
which is one
as a biological matter this affects very
very few people i have i can listen i
have no doubt this is a fallen world
some people are born with nine fingers
and 11 toes some people are bored people
are born with all sorts of quirks
because we're all we've all got
imperfections and so sure i'm sure
there's some biological basis for all
sorts of sexual pathologies and
confusions
there's also obviously a social aspect
here you look at gen z the zoomers forty
percent of them four zero percent of
them identify as lgbt so either alex
jones is right and there's something in
the water turning all of the freaking
frogs gay or there's a social aspect
here that's not really rooted in any
kind of born this way or or natural or
even even
you know
natural environmental factor that's
going on
but what's what's amazing here is that
as technology advances
the physical aspects of our lives seem
to matter less and less and less
you you hear this from our ruling elites
all around the world not just in our
country from but all around the world
the world economic forum talking about
the great reset right where they say
you're going to work from home a lot
more you're not going to go to an office
you're not going to see people
too much you hear it from facebook where
mark zuckerberg says you're not going to
go to bars and meetings and birthday
parties and weddings you're just you're
going to sit in your little apartment
and you're going to put goggles on and
you're going to live in a candyland
world that i made myself and then you're
going to interact with cartoon versions
of people you're going to leave the real
world created by god for your
flourishing and you're going to go into
a creepy video game invented by a lizard
person named mark zuckerberg that's a
isn't that a great trade
why would you want this world with you
know the over the brave or hanging
firmament
the the majestical roof fretted with
stars the beautiful wildlife the flora
the fauna everything all of our real
loves and hopes and joys why would you
live in that world given to us by our
incomprehensible all-loving creator when
you can live in a weird video game made
by a human lizard wouldn't that be in
your little pod that you don't you're
not allowed to leave because you know
there are germs outside where you just
eat the bugs it's very important they're
a good source of protein make sure you
eat the bugs
our elites tell us isn't that great and
your physical body
in this hellish dystopia
does not matter as much and what
transgenderism says is
your body doesn't matter as much yeah my
body i look like a man i talk like a man
i've got this uh deep slightly gravely
voice because my allergies are acting up
it's not just one too many cigars but
you can see i've got an adam's apple i
look like a fella but deep down
i'm really a lady and that's that's all
there is to it
agnostic heresy
as i said it all
we get dumber every year we get in our
modern world we've never been so stupid
because what we're seeing with this
transgenderism issue is nothing more
than the same old gnostic heresy that's
been going on for thousands of years and
every few hundred years every 500 years
or so rears its ugly head to try to
destroy civilization
beta o'rourke made an important point
there
he said texas is big enough for
everybody
sure i mean i the thing is that there's
no such thing as a transgender
non-binary person i'm not saying the
people who believe that they are that
don't exist but it's a category error
that category of person doesn't exist
it's a delusion and delusions should not
be encouraged
but is it is it big is texas big enough
it's not big enough for all these ideas
frankly the country is not big enough
for all these people
we're running out of time so we'll have
to get to this tomorrow
a shocking new number just came out the
number of immigrants in the united
states legal and illegal has hit a
record high 46.6 million
in january it's up 1.6 million just in
the last year since joe biden was
inaugurated
this is part of a bigger problem i mean
i mean no disrespect to any immigrants
from any country that they come from
that's just too many that's just too
many foreigners in a country to have a
country a country precedes by having
traditions by having
bonds of of
friendship and citizenship
common language a common experience you
can let immigrants in i'm not saying to
shut immigrants out entirely but you
can't just flood the country with an
entirely new people and expect to have
the same country it's not possible and
we are seeing that we are seeing borders
changing countries changing left and
right whether it's in eastern europe or
even more distressing perhaps right here
at home i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show vladimir
putin begins a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and throws the world order on
its head that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen